- [Instructor] So why do we care
about the Market Revolution?
The Industrial Revolution
and the Transportation
and the Communication Revolutions
of the early 19th century
had a major impact on American society,
both in the short term
and in the long term.
In this video, I want to talk
about three major effects
of the Market Revolution,
and those were changes
in labor, entry into a national
and international market system
and the Second Great Awakening.
All right, so what effect
did the Market Revolution have on labor?
Well, we've already talked
about this a little bit
in the earlier videos, but here is a view
of a textile factory floor.
Now this is from a slightly later period,
but I think it gives you a
good sense of what it was like
to work in a textile factory.
With the Market Revolution
really comes the emergence
of factory labor in the United States.
And there are a couple of
ways that, that's important.
One is that people
start working for wages.
It's a move away from subsistence farming
and a barter economy,
which also means that
people aren't necessarily in
charge of themselves anymore.
And there's a lot that
goes along with that,
which means that people
stop being their own bosses.
Instead, they report to other bosses.
And that can be problematic because
it means that you have a lot less control
over your daily life.
So imagine that you're a
farmer and you're really sick.
Oh well, you know maybe you
don't plant some seed that day
and you do it the next day.
Imagine that you work at a textile mill
and you get really sick,
you don't report to work
and you get fired.
So people are no longer
able to set the pace
of their own lives by and large.
And with things like
interchangeable parts, for example,
fewer and fewer artisans,
so masters of a craft,
are making goods from start to finish.
So it used to be perhaps you
would be a master shoemaker,
a master cobbler, and you would
make every part of that shoe
from tanning the leather
to nailing in the sole.
The system of interchangeable parts,
which will later become even more codified
as the assembly-line system,
means that most people are only doing
one part of a task.
So instead of doing all of
making a shoe and saying
at the end of it, "I made this shoe,
"I am a master maker of
shoes," now your entire job
might just be to hammer in one nail
and then hand off the
shoe to the next person.
So there's never anything
that you can point to
and say, "I made that."
So a lot of people say
that this is a period
when people stop being able to
take pride in their own work
or at least not as much pride.
But what's even more
important about this process
of interchangeable parts,
assembly-line labor,
is that it leads to an overall,
what they call, deskilling.
So removing the skill from labor.
And what's important about that is that
if you've broken down a
task into enough small parts
that you've got people
literally hammering in
the same nail on a different
shoe 12 hours a day,
then you don't necessarily
need highly trained artisans
to do that.
And what happens if you
are not highly trained,
we'll call this unskilled labor,
and you decide you want to
strike for higher pay?
Well, your boss doesn't
need to train anyone
to hammer in that nail
so you'll just get fired.
So it makes the labor force in general
a little bit more precarious
because you don't need
an exceptional skill
to have a factory job,
but you are easily replaced.
All right, let's talk about
entry into a market system.
Now what do I mean by this?
In this time period, the
United States develops
what's called a market economy.
And that's different from what
most people had been doing
up until that point because
people in the United States
had mainly shipped raw materials
over to Europe, England particularly,
to be processed and made
into finished goods.
And this is similar to
the system of mercantilism
that you might be familiar
with from the colonial era.
Well, the war of 1812
and some of the conflict
leading up to it, led the United
States to embargo England,
which was a manufacturing center.
So people couldn't send
their raw materials there.
They responded by investing
in their own factories.
So the war of 1812 is actually
a pretty important moment
for the development of domestic
industrialization at home.
And so now, instead of
this kind of import/export
or barter economy, people are making deals
with other investors all
over the United States,
all over the world.
So this gives people an
opportunity to invest
and to speculate.
And that means that as they're a part
of an international market
of investment speculation,
they're prone to the
kinds of booms and busts
that characterize capitalism, right?
Now we often think of the Great Depression
as having been the first
major American depression.
But really, it was the
largest and most recent
up until that point, because
after the war of 1812,
the United States kinda
goes through approximately
a 20-year cycle of boom and bust.
So boom is when things are getting better,
things are looking up, the
economy is going really well,
and then a bubble of some kind bursts.
And in 1819, they had the very
first of these bubbles burst,
it's called the Panic of
1819 in land speculation.
And this is the first time
that the United States
had actually experienced any
kind of economic depression.
So imagine how frightening
that would have been to them.
One of the hardest things
about market-based capitalism
is that individuals
don't really have control
over the larger market.
It's not one person that made
the Great Depression happen.
It was an overall loss
in consumer confidence
or perhaps overproduction, right?
If too many people are
supplying the same commodity,
the price is dropping through
the laws of supply and demand.
So now, the laws of supply
and demand and the pressures
of an international
market are really changing
the nature of American commerce because
they're enmeshed in that market.
And that has all kinds of
political and social ramifications
for the United States.
Understanding the volatility of belonging
to an international market
kind of helps explain why Andrew Jackson
was so obsessed with the National Bank
at this time period, right?
Because it represents
this confusing matrix
of international supply and demand
and people getting credit
or not getting credit.
And being part of this
international market
is something that's going
to have a major effect
on the American South, and particularly
the enslaved population that
lives in the American South
because they're going
to be supplying cotton
to the world's textile mills.
And those are textile mills in New England
and textile mills in England.
And as the world demands
cotton for processing,
the South is going to supply that cotton,
which is picked by enslaved individuals.
And one of the reasons that
the Confederacy believes
that it can succeed as
an independent nation
is because they're
supplying cotton to England.
And when England managed to
find its own supply of cotton
from Egypt and India, the economic chances
of the Confederacy were sunk.
And the last thing that I
think is related to this
Market Revolution is the
Second Great Awakening.
Now I don't wanna go into
too much detail about this
because of a whole
separate series of videos
about the Second Great Awakening,
but this Second Great Awakening
was kind of an explosion
of religious fervor, which was happening
at almost exactly the same
time as the Market Revolution.
And many American
historians actually think
that it's these confusing and confounding
and anxious forces that
lead a lot of people
to take up religion.
Because as the world is
changing around them,
as people now have to
relate in different ways
to their neighbors as bosses and employees
rather than bartering partners,
and as they're swept up
in international markets
that are outside their control,
people look for new explanations
and comfort in an increasingly
confusing world.
So that's one explanation for
the Second Great Awakening.
So I started out this series
of videos by saying that
some historians have argued
that the Market Revolution
was actually more revolutionary
than the American Revolution.
Now that's a difficult question to answer
because we're talking about
a revolution in politics
as opposed to kind of a
revolution of economics.
But I will say that though
the American Revolution
dissolved the political bonds
between the United States
and Great Britain, its
social and economic impact
were relatively limited.
Most people kind of ended
up in the same place
socially after the American Revolution
as they were before it.
But the Market Revolution
changes an awful lot
in American society in terms of
how they participate internationally
and how people organize their daily lives.
So I think there is a
strong argument to be made
that this revolution of
economics, technology,
even religion, is
considerably farther reaching
than the American Revolution.